[Music]
mr. Kim you're sitting with a man who
does bad things to good people
you owe me four hundred thousand dollars
you have 72 hours beginning now probably
asking yourself how I got into this
situation let's go back a few days we're
all there for Tommy's annual celebrity
death pool party my pink in the pool
every year is David Hasselhoff
whoever celebrity died first would walk
away with $500,000 this is gonna be on
you we own a Hollywood Club guys it's
gonna be a big night we got us a little
problem what is going on in my VIP suite
oh I'm accused of dealing drugs sexual
assault plus I look 400 grand to a
goddamn psychopath tell me where I can
find Chris Kim is in some stupid
celebrity death pool if David Hasselhoff
dies we win half a million dollars a
half mil I want a piece of that I do too
I will help you with anything you need
to kill the death pool money that night
makes no sense so you up to speed on
what we need you to do yeah there's a
shame though I'm a fan of David
Hasselhoff here beautiful man you people
confuse the hell out of me black people
no gay people okay that's confusing so
people I'll get it
I actually wrote a list of the many ways
to kill done scarf court and sidecar
because I can know
what's going on he's been way over his
head
yes yes I'm thinking suppose it go long
not dexter or anything no if he plans
things out hey them what you like oh no
I just play one on TV why is he running
in slow motion that's the sexiest [ __ ]
I've seen in my life
[Music]
you know I'll murder you right here or
murder that ass is there another choice
you